dear friends, today I once again appeal
to all citizens of Russia
Thank you for your endurance, unity and
patriotism,
this Civil Solidarity has shown
that any blackmail attempts to arrange
internal unrest are doomed to failure,
I repeat, the highest
consolidation of society,
the executive and legislative powers
at all levels, was shown a firm unequivocal
position in support of the constitutional
order  occupied by public organizations
religious denominations leading
political parties
in fact the entire Russian society
armed rebellion in any case would have been
suppressed
by the organizers of the heavy, despite the loss of
adequacy, they could not but understand this.
They understood, among other things, that they
went to criminal actions to split and
weaken the country that are now
resists a colossal external threat to
unprecedented pressure from the outside when our comrades
die at the front with words not a step back.
However, the organizers of the war,
having given their country to their people, betrayed and
those who were dragged into the crime, they lied to them,
pushed them to Death under fire in order
to shoot at their
own Exodus to the brother  the
enemies of Russia and the neo-Nazis in Kiev
and their Western patrons and all sorts of
national traitors
wanted the murders, they wanted the Russian soldiers to kill each
other, we knew and we know that the vast
majority of the fighters and commanders of the
Wagner group are also Russian patriots
loyal to their people and state,
they proved it with their courage  on the
battlefield, liberating the Donbass and Novorossia, they
tried to use them in the dark against
their brothers in arms with whom they
fought together the radio of the country and its
future. Therefore, from the very beginning of the events, on
my direct instructions,
steps were taken to avoid
great bloodshed, I thank those soldiers and
commanders of the Wagner group who  made the
only right decision did not go
for proto-murderous bloodshed
stopped at the last line
today you have the opportunity to
continue serving Russia by signing
a contract with the Ministry of Defense Or
other law enforcement agencies or return
to your family and friends
Who wants to be able to leave for Belarus, the
promise I made will be fulfilled